you know how it is with convertibles
whatever you're playing on those premium
surround sound speakers is what everyone
around you here is too so you're going
to have to bump up your playlist
repertoire just like Mercedes has bumped
up the tuning on this two-seat toy this
is the $84,000 convertible Mercedes made
as a way to inject the previous SL 350
with some real aggression but also to
offer something more affordable than the
AMG equivalent Merck made the SL famous
60 years ago with the 300 SL but this
version has a 7-speed automatic
transmission on its 329 horsepower v6
engine it has a zero to 60 mile-per-hour
sprit time a 5.1 seconds the SL for
under it is fast and fun and if you
don't want to spend tens of thousands of
dollars more on the AMG versions of this
car you should buy this one
driving the SL 400 feels like piloting a
small speed boat the steering is tight
and quick and the engine roars to life
with just a touch on the gas pedal
you will be fine driving it all day
every day without getting the fatigue
that many sports cars and roadsters give
with their stiff chassis loud engine and
overly tight brakes in fact the SL 400
has creature comforts to mitigate those
very effects these are things like body
roll control optional massaging seats
and the warm air scarf that will blow
hot air onto the back of your neck on
cool summer nights aesthetically the SL
400 will fit right in with the neighbors
in Southampton it has the long nose of
an Afghan hound with a tiny rear end
offset by shredder looking air vents in
the hood people will notice you and make
sure to comment when you drive it inside
the cabin is wrapped in leather wood and
aluminum it feels fantastic until you
want to ride with more than one person
this car fits only two people but with
practically no room in the trunk so
choose your passenger wisely they'll be
occupying a special seat oh and if
they're controlling the radio you're
going to want to make sure their
playlist is up to par
you